LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to the Googleplex.
This is an incredible place
with lots of great stuff being
worked on every single day.
Before I worked here,
I always wondered
what it'd be like to
come to the Googleplex,
meet up with a Googler,
and have coffee with them,
and just chat about what
they do, how they do it,
and why they do it.
And today we're going
to do exactly that.
Welcome to this episode of
"Coffee With A Googler".
Today I have a
very special guest.
You may have seen his face
in the Google Play services
videos, or you may have
had a t-shirt shot at you
during Google I/O. And this is
the man responsible-- Magnus
Hyttsten.
Welcome to Coffee.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
Thank you so much.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Thanks, so tell
us a little bit about yourself
and what you do at Google.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: I've been at
Google for over 1 and 1/2 years
now.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: And the
last year and three months,
I've been working intensively
with Google Play Services.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, cool.
So what is Google Play Services?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: So
Google Play Services
is a layer of APIs that
sits on top of Android.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: And so
for all the applications
that are distributed to
the Google Play Store,
this set of APIs are available
for the app developers.
LAURENCE MORONEY: All right.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: And these
APIs-- they include things
like location, activity
recognition, maps,
and many other things.
There are about 12
APIs in this thing.
And you can use these,
and they will then
connect to the back
end data centers
that Google has to provide
these information services.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, cool.
Now we had Francis Mann on
the show a few weeks back.
And one of the things that
Francis shared with us
was that with the releases
of Google Play Services,
we named them after cheeses.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Correct.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Right, and I hear
the latest one is Parmesan?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
Parmesan, that's correct.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Now you've been
working on some great
release content for Parmesan.
Can you tell us about that?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Absolutely.
So Parmesan-- obviously
being P, we've
released a lot of these things.
On average, we probably release
one Google Play Services
version every two months
or so-- six to eight weeks.
So there's a lot
of functionality
that we're able to
pack into this thing,
and that gets distributed to all
of the users that are connected
to the Google Play Store.
So it's this really a massive
user base that gets this.
Previously, you can
only have one wearable
connected to your phone.
So now, you can have any
number of wearables connected.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh wow.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: So you
can actually run around
with multiple devices
and they're all
interacting in the network
connected to your device.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow, and
you're the hub of this network,
basically.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Haha.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: You can find
a lot of interesting services
that can build around that.
And then we have
enhancements to Google Fit.
Google Fit is quite
a new API, so there
are continuous enhancements
all the time to Google Fit.
And we're really
excited about that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And with that
nice frequent release update
cycle, then bugs
get fixed quickly,
new features get
rolled in quickly.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So there's lots
of good stuff for developers.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: If you're
a developer out developing
applications, just following the
enhancements and functionality
that we push into
Google Play Services
gives you a very
competitive edge
to building new
things that may have
been impossible to do before.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Now one the things
that you're notorious
for is how zanily you
produce this content, right?
So all the release--
all the release videos
have Magnus doing his thing.
We're just going to roll
a quick clip of that now.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: We also
super excited to announce
that we are releasing
Google Play Services 6.5,
enabling you to
build better apps!
And what are we do again?
COMPUTER VOICE: Recording
"Dev Byte", get to work.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That's right!
Fitness, however,
is all about today,
like how many steps
have you taken today?
How many calories have you
put in your body today?
How many pushups
have you done today?
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's nuts.
How do you come up
with all of that?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Well
in the beginning,
it was just an idea to
keep these things funny
and engaging.
And after a while, we
thought, how are we
going to be able to sustain
this-- come up with new things
all the time?
And it kind of solved itself,
because every single release
has new stuff that
you can talk about.
You don't need to
invent anything new.
You can just look the things
that are in the release,
and then you can find many
fun things to do with them.
Like activity
recognition-- obviously
Google Fit is a fantastic
API-- can go out into nature
and do crazy things, right?
You can just imagine
now for Parmesan,
being capable of connecting
multiple wearables
to a device like this.
Obviously, it was too
tempting to resist, right?
So we had to just dress up
all the arms with wearables.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That must have hurt.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Well it took
some time to actually mount
them on, because these straps--
they're not long enough to go
around--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Big
biceps like yours?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: So we
had to use some duct tape
to get that going.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Haha.
That's the dirty
little secret, huh?
Now with all those kind
of crazy stunts and things
that you do in video, something
must have gone wrong somewhere.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
Absolutely, there
are things that go wrong
beyond just the script.
Obviously, when we're doing
these physical things,
with bikes and we're running
around, so we have missteps
and you hurt your
foot or whatever.
I remember biking and
falling off the bike,
because you get really excited.
You want to get this
thing going right.
And you make that little extra
effort to make it exciting.
And in the process
of that, you may
forget your personal security.
So--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Your
personal security.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: So we had some
incidents with respect to that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I heard
something about a wet t-shirt
once.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Oh yeah.
In one of the videos, we had
the activity recognition.
We had this Android voice
speaking to me, saying,
what am I doing now?
You are running.
And things like that.
At the end of that
scene, I was supposed
to come up and
look at Googleplex
and be all wet,
simulating sweat,
but obviously, we had water.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: The problem
is that, that scene did not
go well and we only
had one t-shirt.
So we were standing
there with a wet T-shirt
and we needed to re-record
that scene, right?
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: So we
just had to be run over
to the Google store
and buy another T-shirt
and get on it again.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Did
you film that scene last,
or did you film it first?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah,
it was the last scene,
so that was a good thing.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, so
that's not so bad, cool.
Now Google I/O last
year, you had a session,
and I hear it was a really
highly engaging session,
and you even brought
a T-shirt launcher?
Is that right?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That's right.
We thought, how do we
make Google I/O engaging?
How can we actually
get the audience
interacting with the speech?
Because you're sitting there and
it's hundreds of people down,
and you can't ask
specific questions
or engage with
individual people.
So we got this idea
from a TV show,
and we essentially ordered
a T-shirt launcher.
It's sitting down right
there in my cabinet now.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Haha, I know where
I'm going when we're
done shooting this video.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Under my desk,
right, just sitting there.
I haven't been using it
since Google I/O last year.
So Google I/O is
coming up soon, so I
think it's a good opportunity
to, in the next couple of days,
take that thing out
and see if it works.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Sounds like fun.
So we'll be seeing you
at I/O again this year?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Absolutely,
I'll have a lot of fun.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah, I'm
looking forward to it, too.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: OK.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Well thanks
so much, Magnus, for coming.
This was a whole lot of fun.
We learned so much.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Thank you.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Thanks everybody
for watching this far.
This was Magnus Hyttsten talking
about Google Play Services.
We called it Parmesan,
but it's also Release 7.3.
So watch out for his video.
And if you have any questions
for Magnus or for me,
please leave them in
the comments below.
And please also subscribe to
the Google Developers YouTube
channel, and you'll see lots
of videos like Magnus' release
videos for Google
Play Services, as well
as lots of other great stuff.
Thanks again, and
thanks again, Magnus.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Thank you.